[موسيقى]
تاهب عسكري في بولندا بعد نشر موسكو جزءا
من ترسانتها النوويه في بيلاروسيا واشنطن
سابق الزمن لتطوير صواريخ فرض صوتيه هذه
الملفات وغيرها نطرحها معكم في حلقه اليوم
اهلا بكم في عسكري تاليا
اعلنت اسرائيل مواصله اختباراتها الفنيه
لاحدث اقمارها الصناعيه الاستخباراتيه
افكفورتينغ القمر الذي اطلقته تل ابيب في
نهايه شهر مارس الماضي مزود احدث القدرات
التشغيليه والتقنيه كما انه سيقوم بسلسله
اوليه من عمليات التفتيش قبل الاعلان عن
تشغيله القمر الصناعي تستخدمه الوحده 9900
الاسرائيليه وهي فرع السري داخل الجيش
الاسرائيلي وتشارك في تحليل وتفسير وفهم
صور وخرائط الاقمار الصناعيه
[موسيقى]
تتعاون شركات
نورسون لتقديم عطاءات على طائره القياده
والسيطره التاليه للبحريه الامريكيه هذا
طبعا لاستخدامها في حاله اندلاع حرب نوويه
حيث تسعى البحريه الامريكيه لتطوير
اسطولها المكون من طائرات اي سكس بيمر
كيوري وهي طائرات يوم القيامه التي تستخدم
لتامين الرئيس وكذلك القيادات العسكريه
وايضا توفير مقر قياده وسيطر مركزي للجيش
حاله تعرض لهجمات تمثل تهديدا وجوديا
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه العمل على
تعزيز دفاعاتها الصاروخيه الجويه لحمايه
العاصمه موسكو هذا جاء بعد تعرض عدد من
المدن الروسيه لهجمات بمصيرات اطلقها
الاوكرانيه البرنامج الروسيه يتضمن نشر
مئه كتيبه دفاع جوي وايضا 800 منصه تتكون
من انظمه صواريخ اس 4 واس 350 وايضا اس
500 والتي تعد من احدث منظومات الدفاع
الجوي الروسي على ان يتم الانتهاء من هذه
الخطه قبل نهايه هذا العام هذا طبعا طبقا
لحديث وزير الدفاع الروسي
منذ بدايه الهجوم الروسي على اوكرانيا
كانت بولندا سباقه في تقديم ما لديها في
ترسانتها من ذخائر ودبابات وكذلك نصف ما
لديها من مقاتلات ماك 29 الى الاوكرانيين
لتكون ثاني دوله في حلف الناتو تقدم
طائرات حربيه لكيافه بولندا على الجانب
الاخر
ذهبت مؤخرا لتوقيع على عدد من الصفقات
العسكريه مع الولايات المتحده هذا الامر
جعل مراقبين يرون بانها قريبا ستصبح واحده
من اهم القوه في اوروبا الشرقيه لمناقشه
التطورات العسكريه وكذلك الخطوات التي
اتخذتها بولندا تجاه دعم اوكرانيا وايضا
تقييم مدى استعداديه الجيش البولندي لاي
تطورات ميدانيه معنى من وارسو الجنرال
جوفسكي نائب رئيس الاركان الاسبق للجيش
البولندي وممثل بولندا السابق في المجلس
العسكري لحلف الناتو اولا السيد اهلا بك
معنا في عسكريتاريا يعني على مدى عام
واكثر قدمت بولندا لاوكرانيا دبابات وكذلك
نصف ما لديها من مقاتلات مايك 29 لماذا كل
هذا الدعم العسكري من بولندا لاوكرانيا
وكذلك مدى تاثير هذا الدعم على الاستعداد
العسكري
في المستقبل
شكرا جزيلا لكم على الاستضافه في هذا
البرنامج
هذه لحظات حاسمه للغايه بالنسبه الينا
وينبغي ان نتذكر ان بولندا تقع في بيئه
جغرافيه خطيره وهو وضع استمر لعقود من
الزمن
وبولندا تقع على ممرات مهمه بين الشرق
والغرب وهو امر مفيد للتجاره الدوليه لكنه
لا يخدم المصالح الامنيه
بولندا تقع كذلك على حدود بلد تعرض للهجوم
وهي البلد الاوروبي الوحيد الذي يعيش في
هذه البيئه الجغرافيه وبولندا لديها ايضا
بلد جار صعب للغايه لذلك ينبغي ان نبذل
قصار جهودنا من اجل تحسين اوضاعنا الامنيه
[موسيقى]
فيما يتعلق بالصفقات العسكريه مؤخرا اجرت
بولندا وقامت بالتوقيع على عدد كبير من
الصفقات العسكريه لكن الى اي مدى هذه
الصفقات تلبي الاحتياجات الفعليه للجيش
البولندي في هذه المرحله
[موسيقى]
ما تتساءل عنه الجيوش دائما هو ما الحجم
من حيث العدد والمعدات التي يمكن اعتبارها
كافيه بالنسبه اليها
لا سيما فيما يخص عدد الدبابات والطائرات
وغير ذلك وبالنسبه للاعتبارات الامنيه
فاننا نتعامل مع وضع يتميز بالصعوبه وهو
غير واضح المعالم في جميع الاحوال لكن
الحرب التي تدور راحاها في جوارنا تتسبب
في تسريع الكثير من البرامج الدفاعيه
لدينا ويسري هذا التسريع على شتى المجالات
وبكل بساطه ليس لدينا الوقت الذي يسمح لنا
بتبني نهج يتسم بالبطء بغيه بلوغ اهدافنا
في ظل استمرار هذه الحرب التي تجعلنا نسرع
الخطى حتى نكون جاهزين لمواجهه الاوضاع
الصعبه السائده وفي الوقت ذاته فان الدعم
واسع النطاق الذي نقدمه لاوكرانيا والذي
شمل على سبيل المثال مدها بنحو ثلاثمائه
دبابه يستوجب استبدال هذه المعدات
العسكريه باخرى جديده لذلك يتعين علينا ان
نبحث في اطار برنامج التحديث الذي يخضع له
جيشنا عن السبل الكفيله بتمكيننا من
الحصول على الذخائر والطائرات والدبابات
وغيرها من المعدات العسكريه التي نزود
اوكرانيا بها
وبطبيعه الحال هذه فرصه فريده من نوعها
تتاح لنا للتخلص من العتاد العسكري الذي
يعود الى الحقبه السوفييتيه والذي لا يزال
موجودا لدينا
وربما يسمح لنا هذا الامر بتحقيق قفزه
نوعيه لكن برنامج تحديث القوات المسلحه في
بولندا هو برنامج ضخم ولدينا لائحه
مشتريات العسكريه ضخمه في الوقت الراهن
لكن الملاحظه جنرال في الكاوسكي واعنيك
كما تفضلت بانه الكثير من هذه الصفقات هي
صفقات لاسلحه بنيت على عقيده غربيه سواء
اسلحه اوروبيه او حتى اسلحه امريكيه
السؤال في هذا الاطار الى اي مدى الجندي
في بولندا والمقاتل في بولندا مستعد
للتعامل مع هذه المعدات ومع هذه الاسلحه
خاصه بانه لديه تاريخ في التعامل مع معدات
كما ذكرت معدات سوفيتيه بالكامل
ان الاسلحه التي تحتاج اليها بولندا لا
تصلها بالطبع بين عشيه وضحاها بل يتم
تسليمها على المدى القريب والمتوسط
والبعيد بالنظر الى تلبيه متطلبات التدريب
والاحتياجات اللوجستيه الاخرى
على سبيل المثال لن نحصل على 250 دبابه
ابرمز دفعه واحده وانما سوف يتم تسليم هذه
الدبابات الى بولندا على دفعات وينبغي
الاشاره ايضا الى ان السلطات بلادنا قد
قررت زياده عدد افراد قواتنا المسلحه من
نحو 150 الفا الى ثلاثمائه الف جندي كما
سيتم انشاء اقسام اخرى في اطار برنامج
التحديث علاوه على ذلك شهدت ميزانيه
الدفاع في بولندا زياده والخطه الاساسيه
كانت ترتكز على مقاربه تدريجيه بدءا
بزياده الميزانيه لنحو اثنين في المئه من
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي وهي النسبه التي
تم تحديدها من قبل حلف الناتو لكننا نرغب
في تحقيق زياده في ميزانيه الدفاع تصل الى
ثلاثه في المئه من الناتج المحلي وهي
زياده هائله وهذه كلها تطورات ناجمه عن
الاحداث التي نشهدها حاليا ونظرا لان
متطلبات الامن لا تقع فقط على كاهل الجيش
وانما يطلع بها الجميع في بولندا فاننا
نعمل على التكيف مع الاوضاع السائده باسرع
ما يمكن وقد ابرمنا صفقه لشراء اثنتين
وثلاثين طائره من طراز افخم 35 وسوف نسلم
اوكرانيا 20 طائره من طراز 29 كما وقعنا
عقدا لشراء خمسه واربعين طائره حربيه من
كوريا الجنوبيه واشترينا طائرات مسيره من
طراز بيرقدار من تركيا ونستخدم ايضا
طائرات مسيره حصلنا عليها من الولايات
المتحده
ووقعنا كذلك عقدا لشراء قمرين صناعيين
فرنسيين الى جانب عقد اخر لشراء منظومه
راجمات صواريخ ونحو الف دبابه من كوريا
الجنوبيه هذا جهد جبار يبذل في اطار تحديث
الجيش البولندي
صوت
جنرال في بدايه حديثك تحدثت عن البيئه
الجغرافيه والدول المحيطه في بولندا ووصفت
بانها في موقع جغرافي صعب وتحدثت عن
بيلاروسيا مؤخرا اعلنت موسكو نشر قنابل
تكتيكيه في بيلاروسيا نوويه اولا كيف ترى
هذه الخطوه وهل هذا سيدفع حلف الناتو لنشر
اسلحه نوويه في بولندا في المستقبل القريب
وما هو موقف بولندا كذلك في هذا الاطار
بالنسبه للموقف البولندي هذا سؤال يوجه
الى السلطات البولنديه فما انا سوى جنرال
متقاعد ولا يسعني سوى التكهن بشان هذا
الامر لكن ما استطيع قوله هو ان روسيا
تتعمد زياده مخاطر استخدام الاسلحه
النوويه وهذه السرديه ترددت كثيرا الحرب
البارده لان كل الاطراف كانت تثير مساله
اللجوء الى الاسلحه النوويه لكنها لم تكن
تتقاتل فيما بينها كما لم يكن بمقدور احد
ان يدرك ما يمكن ان تؤول اليه التهديدات
اما بالنسبه لما نشهده حاليا فان التهديد
باستخدام الاسلحه النوويه تكرر اكثر من
مره وهو امر غايه في الخطوره غير ان خبراء
كثرا يعتقدون ان خطر استخدام الاسلحه
النوويه ضئيل جدا ولا يتجاوز نسبه خمسه في
المئه وفقا لمقال طلعت عليه وروسيا قررت
الان ان تشمل معادلتها النوويه بلدنا
الجار بيلاروسيا وهو امر خطير للغايه الا
انني لا اعتقد ان بيلاروسيا بقدورها اتخاذ
قرار من هذا القبيل لان روسيا هي من لها
الكلمه الفصل روسيا
تحث خطاها وتستخدم خطاب الحرب البارده
الجديده او الحرب العالميه الجديده بغيت
التهديد والترويع ودفع بلدان ليس لديها
الرغبه في الانضمام الى فضاء النفوذ
الروسي
جنرال كوفسكي نائب رئيس الاركان الاسبق
للجيش البولندي شكرا جزيلا على وجودك معنا
سلاح اثبت نجاحه منذ بدايه الحرب بات
ظهوره على شاشات الرادار يدفع بالقوات
الاوكرانيه لاطلاق صافرات الانذار بل
وتوجيه المقاتلات الاوكرانيه بالابتعاد
للحفاظ على سلامتها هذا طبعا يعود لقدرتها
على اطلاق صواريخ فرد صوتيه المقاتله
الروسيه الهجوميه مج واحد وثلاثين اول
مقاتله من الجيل الرابع في الاتحاد
السوفيتي تعد 31 واحده من اسرع المقاتلات
في العالم اذ تصل سرعتها حتى ثلاثه الاف
كيلو متر في الساعه الواحده كما تحلق على
ارتفاعات عاليه عند تنفيذ مهام هجوميه او
قتاليه هذا الامر ابقاها بمامن من النيران
الاوكرانيه
صممت مقاتله الميغا 31 لتكون مقاتله
اعتراضيه يمكنها التصدي لمقاتلات او حتى
قاذفات استراتيجيه على ارتفاعات شاهقه يصل
حتى اثنين وثمانين الف قدمه دخلت هذه
المقاتله الخدمه في سلاح الجو السوفيتي في
عام
لكنها شهدت عده عمليات تحديث وتطوير
حولتها لاحدى اهم الطائرات الاعتراضيه في
الترسانه الروسيه حتى هذه اللحظه مثلا هي
المقاتله الوحيده المسلحه بصواريخ ار 37
وهي صواريخ جو جو فرد صوتيه مضاده
للطائرات معروفه لدى حلف الناتو باسم
صواريخ ارو كما تم تعديل بعض طائرات ميج
31 لتتمكن من حمل واطلاق صواريخ جو ارض من
طراز كنزال فرط الصوتيه هذه الصواريخ التي
الحقت خسائر كبيره بالاوكرانيين بل ولعبت
دورا حاسما في تدمير جزء كبير من البنيه
التحتيه لعدد من المدن الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
بعد الفاصل تفوق صيني روسي على الولايات
المتحده في سباق تصنيع الصواريخ فرط
الصوتيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد تسعى الولايات المتحده
جاهده للاحتفاظ بتفوقها الجوي على مستوى
العالم بعد التقدم الكبير الذي ظهر خلال
السنوات الاخيره في القدرات الصينيه وكذلك
على الجانب الاخر ظهور تكتلات دوليه
لتطوير مقاتلات من الجيل السادس
اعتقد انه من المهم ان ندرك ان الولايات
المتحده قد احرزت الكثير من التقدم مبكرا
في الماضي في مجال الاسلحه فرط الصوتيه
لكنها لم ترى مزايا هذا تقدم بعد ذلك
وخلال سنوات الثلاثين الماضيه ولا سيما
خلال فتره زمنيه التي اعقبت احداث الحادي
عشر من سبتمبر بدات كل من الصين وروسيا في
تطوير اسلحه بعيده المدى واسعه الى اكتساب
مزايا تفاضليه وقد نجح البلدان في تحقيق
الكثير من التقدم في هذا المجال وبوسعي ان
اقول ان البلدين متقدمان على الولايات
المتحده فيما يخص التكنولوجيا فرط الصوتيه
وهو امر يدفع باتجاه تغيير بعض الابعاد
الاستراتيجيه لكنني اعتقد ان الاسلحه فرط
الصوتيه هي اكثر اهميه بالنسبه للصين مما
عليه بالنسبه للولايات المتحده
فيما يتعلق بمقاتله جيت وانت الصينيه بكين
اعلنت بانه هذه المقاتله تمتلك القدرات
الشبحيه على الجانب الاخر فيما يتعلق
بالولايات المتحده هل هذا يعني ان
المقاتلات الامريكيه فقدت احتكارها لمثل
هذه التكنولوجيا ومنعكاسه على القوات
الجويه الامريكيه كذلك
اعتقد ان ما يميز طائره الشبح هي قدرتها
على القيام بعمليات المراقبه على مستويات
المنخفضه ومعرفه تهديدات القادمه وهي امور
قد لا تتاح لاجهزه الرادار والواضح ان
الصين ادركت قيمه تكنولوجيا الطائرات
الشبح التي طورتها الولايات المتحده وساعت
الحصول على هذه التكنولوجيا لتعزيز
قدراتها العسكريه بها مكتفيه بذلك اثر
روسيا بهذا الشان واعتقد ان الصين احرز
التقدما اكبر مما حققته روسيا في هذا
المجال وربما سوف يزيل هذا التقدم الصيني
بعد عناصر الاحتكار الذي تتميز به الطائره
الشبح الامريكيه دون ان يعني ذلك حرمان
الولايات المتحده من جميع المزايا التي
وفرتها لها الطائره الشبح الامريكيه
الطائره الشبح تجعل مهمه تحديد الاهداف
القادمه اكثر صعوبه وتعقيدا وتقلل فتره
الانذار المبكره
لا اعتقد ان امتلاك الصين خاصيه الشبح لن
يغير الامر كثيرا بالنسبه لامريكا لانه في
نهايه المطاف عندما تتم اضافه قدرات جديده
لتحديث الدفاع الجوي فهذا يقلل من تهديد
طائرات الشبح وبالتالي فهي لن تؤثر على
دوله تمتلك نظام دفاع جوي متكامل
فيما يتعلق بمقاتلات الجيل السادس هناك
الكثير من المشاريع سواء في اوروبا وحتى
في الصين او حتى في اسيا في هذه المرحله
لكن فيما يتعلق بالمشروع الامريكي لتطوير
مقاتله من الجيل السادس كيف تقيم البرنامج
الامريكي في هذا الاطار
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه لطائرات الجيل السادس يستطيع
الانسان القول ان قاذفه بي 21 التي دخلت
الخدمه في شهر ديسمبر الماضي كانت اضافه
كبيره اما فيما يخص طائرات الجيل السادس
فهذا باعتقاد موضوع قابل للنقاش لان الامر
يتعلق بما توفره الطائره الشبح من قدرات
يضاف اليها عناصر الحرب الالكترونيه
ولغايه المتمثله في قدرته على التخفي عن
اجهزه الرادار مع الاستعانه بالوسائل
التكنولوجيه للتصدي للتهديدات القادمه اما
بالنسبه للاسلحه من الجيل السادس فهي
تتميز بقدراتها التدميريه والقاذفه بواحد
وعشرين تتميز بوسائل التحكم التي تتمتع
بها الطائرات المقاتله فضلا عن قدراتها
الجويه الخاصه والمعززه بقدرته على
استخدام الطائرات المسيره التي تحلق الى
جانب الطائرات المقاتله وهو امر يضيف
المزيد من التعقيدات التي تواجهها نظام
الدفاع الجوي التي التي تتصدى لهذه
الطائرات
مصر دبيس على ذكر الطائرات المسيره هناك
اهتمام دولي كبير الان بمجال الطائرات
المسيره لكن هل تعتقد بان الطائرات
المسيره التي تعمل بتقنيه الذكاء
الاصطناعي هل تؤثر على الطائرات التقليديه
في يوم من الايام وكذلك على مهنه التيار
ايضا بشكل عام
بالتاكيد ما سيكون واضحا للعيان هو ان اي
قائد لطائره من الجيل السادس او الخامس
مثل طائره اف 35 ستكون لديه قدره تحكم ليس
في الطائرات المقاتله فحسب بل وفي الطائره
المسيره التي تحلق الى جوار طائرته ايضا
بشكل تعاوني ويشمل ذلك مشاركه الطائرات
المسيره في الحرب الالكترونيه كما يمكن
تزويدها باسلحه اضافيه ناهيك عن قدراتها
الهجوميه المستقله التي قد تتمتع بها مثل
الصواريخ جو جو وفي هذه الحاله يصبح
الطيار قادرا على تحكم في جميع هذه
الوسائل واتخاذ القرار بسرعه اكبر
رئيس تحرير مجله القوات الجويه شكرا جزيلا
على كل ما تفضلت به من توضيحتك
[تصفيق]
بعد خساره هتلر لقرابه نصف مليون من جنوده
في الحرب العالميه الثانيه اضطر الزعيم
النزيل لتجنيد الاطفال وكبار السن
وبالتالي كانت الحاجه للسلاح خفيف يتناسب
مع قدراتهم البدنيه المحدوده لهذا كان
البانزر فاوس او القبضه باللغه العربيه
هذا السلاح الذي صممته القوات النازيه
خلال الحرب العالميه الثانيه لعب دورا
فعالا في وقت متاخر من الحرب اعتبر مثلا
اول صاروخ مضاد للدروع يطلق يدويا
باستخدام قاذف لمره واحده فقط عرف بسهوله
استخدامه وقدرته على اختراق المدرعات بل
وتدميرها احيانا صدرت منه نسخ عده بمدى
مختلف اشهرها القاذفات بمدى يتراوح بين 30
و60 كم
بلغ وزن هذا السلاح بين ثلاثه وسبعه كيلو
جرامات بحسب الاصدار وهو ما جعله مثاليا
للمراهقين وكبار السن
ينسب للبنزر فاوست الفضل في تدمير المئات
من الدبابات السوفيتيه وعلى راسها ايضا
دبابه تي 34 وهو ما جعل البعض يلقبه بسلاح
الانتقام النازيه
حلقه عسكري تاليه لهذا الاسبوع قد انتهت
الاسبوع المقبل المزيد من الاسلحه والمزيد
من الصفقات في امان الله
[موسيقى]